hello
and welcome to another u.s edition of
spectator tv
first up let me tell you about this
year's special christmas offer for the
spectators of american edition for 52
dollars that's just a dollar a week
you'll get a full subscription to the
spectators 88-page
classy monthly american magazine plus
full
access to our brilliant american website
we'll even throw in a free fancy parker
pen
you can scribble your objections
straight onto the pages
just go to spectator dot u s slash
christmas
to subscribe that's spectator dot us
christmas to subscribe now on to the
show
i'm joined by stephen walt professor of
international affairs at harvard
and author of the hell of good
intentions american foreign policy
elite and the decline of u.s primacy
bill bernard
historian former president of democrats
abroad uk
and the spectators team usa our
washington
uh editor amber athey who just joined us
in a few moments
and freddie gray our u.s editor now
just about everybody beyond the oval
office and the nether regions of social
media
now accepts that joe biden will be the
46th president of the united states
and today we'll discuss what a biden
presidency might look like
of course mr trump has yet to concede
and his various legal teams
so insist that they've got reams of
damning evidence
showing widespread electoral fraud the
problem is
that uh what they have has been thrown
out in court when they've gone there
and a lot of it hasn't even been
presented to court
within days the electoral college will
vote and bearing some extraordinary
reversal
joe biden will be formally confirmed as
america's 46th president
but before we get to him let's start by
asking all of you
how you think the trump presidency ends
first of all to you stephen will trump
do you think will mr trump disappear
after the biden inauguration
or is this refusal to concede so far is
it designed
to set him up for another run in 2024
i think it's certainly designed to leave
the option open
if that seems like an attractive
possibility to him
one of the things we've learned about
donald trump really throughout his
entire career is he craves attention
he devotes enormous amounts of effort to
trying to get it
and in a sense marketing his brand has
been more important to him
than actually running an effective
business or running an effective white
house
so i don't see him uh heading off to
retirement to play golf and remaining
silent
he still has you know millions of
twitter followers i suspect that that
twitter feed will remain active
and even if he is busy fighting off
various legal actions
he is not going to disappear from the
public consciousness at least not for a
while
the most interesting question to me is
how the rest of the republican party is
going to react
because there are a number of other
people secretary of state pompeo
marco rubio ted cruz and possibly nikki
haley
who would like to consider running in
2024 and they may not
want donald trump lurking out there as a
possibility
that'll be very interesting to watch it
certainly we're not going to come on to
what it might mean for the republican
party let me go to bill uh now though
but do you see any kind of strategy in
what mr trump is doing at the moment
for the future i think he probably has
more to do with his psychological makeup
than any long-term political strategy he
may very well
and i think he does i entirely agree
that he does want to keep open the
possibility
but you know he's no longer he's no
longer going to be the president of the
united states
so his tweets will not command the
airwaves in the evening
he won't be able to set the press agenda
day by day
as he has done over the last four years
amber would the republican establishment
would it welcome another trump run in
2024 or would that be their worst
nightmare
well i think ultimately they would
probably have no choice but to welcome
it
because they of course were originally
very against the idea of trump in 2015
when he started running in that primary
but
ultimately we're forced to accept him
and he ended up bringing
on a lot of the republican establishment
to his side
because of course they wanted to be able
to use his presidency
to advance their own agenda if he were
to run again in 2024 i think they would
likely do the same thing although the
acceptance would come much quicker
because it would look ultimately very
very bad for the republican party
if they were to shun a former president
who was very very popular
among the party's voters freddie
i mean lots of things can happen but it
could be
with a fair wind mr trump in the
republican primaries could be quite hard
to beat
again could you not i mean if you're
mark rubio or some of the other ones
thinking of having another run
you don't really want him to be there do
you
well i think he's unstoppable uh if he
wants to run it and i'd even go further
and say
in four years time after four years of
joe biden he might be unstoppable as a
presidential candidate for for the white
house again
because his specialty is uh negative
campaigning
um saying that the system is broken
and one of the reasons i think he failed
as he seems to have done this time is
because
he wasn't very good at saying uh i've
fixed the system
uh you just need to let me stop the
establishment again
so i think he will be a very very
formidable candidate
and i think the thing that's going
against him now is how long is he going
to carry on
this uh what at the moment looks like an
embarrassing charade
of contesting this election and how much
do voters
find obviously the people who voted for
him feel robbed
uh we can see that but how much do
you know say if there is a middle ground
in america how much does the middle
ground in america think
come on this election is done we've got
to move on i think that's gonna that
will be the one thing that will stop him
in four years time is if he really
embarrasses himself over this
stephen even if it's not mr trump
he has changed the republican party it's
a different republican party
he's maybe moving in his direction to
some extent but he certainly
increased it so you know it's not the
republican party of the country clubs
anymore it isn't even the kind of reagan
west coast
uh free market limited government uh
republican party anymore
whoever wants to be the next republican
presidential candidate
will need to appeal to quite a lot of
the trump base now will they not
well they'll have to they'll certainly
have to try but this is going to be the
interesting challenge the republican
party faces
i mean first of all i think what it's
shown you is at least at the upper
reaches of the party
there's not an enormous amount of
principle any longer
these are people who said oh you know
horrible things about trump in 2016
how unqualified he was how his character
was fully deficient
and once he became president they became
acolytes
for trump i could easily see the mitch
mcconnells and lindsey grahams
turning away from trump if they didn't
think he
commanded the same magic any longer so
at the upper reaches of the party i
think it's actually
quite flexible the other thing you have
to remember is you know
donald trump got a lower percentage of
the popular vote than mitt romney did
in both his elections both in 2016 and
in 2020
which suggests that although yes he's
got the republican party he does not
have a lock on getting re-elected
right and a lot of this will depend on
exactly what the biden administration
is able to do if they are able to
oversee
the effective rollout of a vaccine and
if the american economy then recovers
relatively briskly
as is fairly likely once a vaccine is
fully deployed
they're going to get enormous credit for
that and trump will try to claim that
you know he did the vaccine he invented
it himself he cooked it up
in the oval office etc but that's not
going to be the way it gets
uh said biden will get enormous credit
if he does that
and that may put the republican party in
a very difficult bind
do we essentially hitch our wagon to
going back
to what we did from 2016 to 2020 which
cost us the white house or do we try to
repackage
the party with a younger candidate a
fresher face
and a slightly different message the
other thing to remember
is that the republican base is not
getting bigger and it's not getting
younger
and the republicans are eventually going
to have to figure out how they appeal to
a broader coalition
than just this very energized base
bill will mr biden feel that it's one of
his roles as
president to win back the blue-collar
workers
to the democratic stable the blue collar
particularly in the rural areas and in
the smaller
uh towns uh of the the rust belt
the midwest will he see that as one of
the main aims that he has to achieve
i think psychologically for him that's
an important thing
certainly to try there was relatively
little but
there was some evidence in the returns
this time that that was
working but not overwhelmingly so by any
means so it'd be very
difficult i think i think to your
earlier question about
2024 and could he would he prevail
against the multiple kansas if there are
multiple candidates if there's a baker's
dozen
as there was last time then trump is
virtually unstoppable
because he will retain that hard core of
support
if as happened in the democratic primary
this past time
the republicans fairly quickly narrow
down to one or two candidates i think it
would be more difficult to him
and as far as a the republican party
turning on a
popular form president that's occurred
before
in 2012 with tr when teddy roosevelt
was unable to get the republican
nomination uh in 2012 and ran as a bull
mooser
i did and heralded in a eight-year
democratic presidency as a result
by splitting the vote and i hadn't been
a democrat in the white house
i think for quite some time until uh mr
wilson
uh took over a british prime minister
once said that a week
is a long time in politics so four years
is a lot longer than a week amber
i mean all sorts of things could happen
uh
i mean is there not a risk that mr trump
could now be so
tied up in all sorts of litigation that
he'd just be unable to run
there's a lot that can happen in four
years i mean if you look back
at the 2012 election for example no one
ever thought that trump would have been
the go-to candidate
in 2016. the idea of it was pretty
unfathomable
and then we also have these stories that
are coming out suggesting that trump's
going to start his own news channel or
perhaps buy out newsmax
and create something like trump tv in
order to keep himself in the spotlight
for the next four years
so i think anything can really happen
and
making too many predictions four years
down the line in politics is a very
dangerous
game indeed and chris ruddy and newsmax
is uh mr trump's close friend
their mates at mar-a-lago club where
they often meet for dinner so who knows
what kind of deals will be done didn't
you see where mr trump will get the
money to buy that newsmax but that's a
another matter here maybe he just added
to his debt
seems to be what everybody's doing these
these days
freddie i wonder whether you know when
you look at the
the election this year it wasn't really
a watershed election
because in the end joe biden was elected
a mainstream
long wrong long-running democrat
but you could see 2024 being a watershed
the democratic party has to determine
what is his future now going through the
2020s
post biden assuming mr biden doesn't run
again
i wouldn't entirely rule that out
wouldn't the republicans also want to
say look we need to decide what kind of
party we're going to be as well
as we go through the 2020s and you can't
really do that if donald trump's still
hanging around
well i think that's exactly right you
you've just got the vanishing center for
both parties
the democrats are going to have to
choose between their base and being an
establishment party and the republicans
are going to have to choose between
their base
and being an establishment party and the
problem for both of them is that all
their votes
are on the wings so i don't really see
how they get it wrong
but going back to trump himself i mean i
wonder whether
the movement that he spawned becomes
something else becomes something
more uh i mean you might already think
that trump's too overtly nationalist
perhaps he is but something more overtly
nationalist
than even trump uh and particularly if
trump
carries on with this slightly
embarrassing charade over the election
for years he might it might become just
a sort of niche interest
and then you'll have a more sort of
nationalist movement emerging on the
right
um so you i mean my the gist of what i'm
saying is it the the extremes are going
to
win in the end i think which way i'm
going forward for the republican party
before we come on to
mr biden and his uh looming presidency
i mean it's clear now certainly this
year and in 2016
elections are won and lost in quite a
narrow
range of states mainly the rust belt uh
the midwest the the west is now a
democratic fiefdom
the northeast is a democratic fiefdom
the south is still largely
republican they'll beginning to free it
more than the edges
but to win an election it seems you need
to win these rust belt states it's why
mr biden won this year is why mr trump
won
in 2016 if not trump amber
what candidate what what is the likely
republican candidate
that can keep that trump support in the
rust belt
and still shore up the south yeah one
person who i think is actually very
underrated and
whose name hasn't really been floated in
these discussions is
florida governor ron desantis who
actually did a really good job managing
the pandemic in his state even though he
was eviscerated by the media for
refusing to do
a full-blown lockdown and really
embraces a lot of the tenets of trumpism
i think ultimately the republican party
would be making a huge mistake
by turning away from that although trump
did end up losing the election
he managed to help the republicans down
ballot gain seats in the house when they
were expected to lose seats in the house
it looks like they're probably going to
hold the senate provided everything in
georgia goes well and
uh some some right wingers don't succeed
with their idea of boycotting the
election
but i saw that but just to to interrupt
you because i saw
there are a number of those on the sort
of a trumpian right
saying it's all the frauds to such and
said
don't vote in the senatorial election i
mean
what are they on if they hit the
christmas sherry early or something
it certainly seems that way and you
would think if the election
was fraudulent then you probably need to
turn out twice the number of votes to
prevent the democrats
so if anything they should stop feeling
it stop filling in the balance yourself
so i interrupted you there just to say
you were saying it does look it
as things stand at the moment
republicans
tight race is still likely to hold on to
the senate that's what i interrupted
yeah that's what it looks like and you
know the republican party was
ultimately very successful in this
election despite losing the presidency
much more successful than they were
expected to be and that's largely
because of the appeal of trumpism
and trump lost not because he didn't
expand his coalition it's actually
because they failed to
turn out white male voters in the
midwest
and that was where he lost a lot of
ground so the republican party really
should have been
making sure to register voters in that
demographic but
it is a good sign that trumpism is
appealing to
a wide swath of voters because trump
overperformed with latinos he
overperformed with black men and women
so this is clearly a winning strategy
for the republican party and if they
turn back the tide to the sort of
libertarian
socially liberal uh
coalition that they had before trump i
just don't see that being appealing to a
large group of voters that doesn't get
the rust bill does it
no it does not stephen i'll give you the
final word on this
i've got one quick yes or no question
for all of you before we move on to mr
biden
this evening i was just picking up what
amber was saying there
i was quite surprised by how strong mr
trump's
coattails were you know it looks like
the democrats haven't got the senate and
if they do it
still have been a hell of a struggle
they lost seats in the house i didn't
see that
coming and in state legislatures up and
down the country the republican
brand was still remarkably strong
given what he's been through these past
uh four years so
give me a final thought on this whether
trump whether the republicans
i i think it depends on how you want to
interpret it because you could argue
that this shows the strength of trumpism
or you could actually show that
what the republicans managed to do was
worry people about what a
unified government under a democratic
president would be able to do you know
painting them as socialists
warning them about the squad suggesting
all sorts of things would happen
if somehow they lost the senate lost the
house
you could also review view this as
it's a repudiation though of trump
what's quite remarkable here is trump
lost in an election where republicans
did well
and i think that's very much a
referendum on this particular president
and to some degree the level of let's
call it social exhaustion
that he's helped uh you know bring to
the country where people are just
tired of the antics they don't want the
country to swing far
to the left but they're not going to be
necessarily all that sorry
to see this particular individual leave
the white house
and that may be something they want to
think about for 2024. he may not be in
fact the best candidate in four years
even if a a conservative candidate
uh has a good chance indeed
he may not as harry wilson said a week
is a long time in uh politics that's
right let me come to the big question
that our viewers around the world want
to know it's
it's the big as mr nixon would have
called it
and it's this will donald trump attend
the inauguration
freddie uh i'm going to go with yes
uh that he will after he will flirt i
think
he will flirt with uh with not going but
he will eventually go that would be my
prediction
but i've got most things wrong in the
trump era so i probably i probably
shouldn't
go it's totally a guess but i would say
no
you would say very interesting yeah i
certainly wouldn't rule out no stephen
i'll say yes and he will attempt to do
something at the inauguration to make
sure that everyone's talking more about
him
than about biden he'll launch trump tv
well he's talking about launching his
his own candidacy for 2024 and then
is that all right amber yeah i think
there's two possibilities he either
attends and is a perfect gentleman
and gives biden the ceremonial gift that
the
outgoing president usually gives the
incoming president or
he actually hosts a rally during the
inauguration
and boasts a crowd of tens of thousands
of people to
distract from the biden inauguration but
is he good
the question was amber is he going to
attend or isn't he
uh right now i say yes yes all right so
more yeses than no there for spectator
tv
reveals exclusively today that donald
trump will attend the inauguration
it's remarkable we're even it's
remarkable we're even
asking the question i mean i cannot find
going back into
my history i don't remember an
inauguration which was never
attended by the outgoing president who
was able to attend is that correct
i don't know of an example no i don't
either i don't either but you
know his uh the niece
of teddy roosevelt once said of him that
his her
uncle always wanted to be the bride at
the wedding and the corpse at the
funeral he couldn't stand not to be the
center of attention
and i think to a significant degree
that's probably true of donald trump as
well
yeah it's true well there were some
similarities though i doubt to from
if donald trump had been shot with a
bullet running from his heart
as teddy roosevelt i don't know if mr
trump would have carried on talking for
45 minutes
the way the then president did right
let's move on to the incoming biden
administration
uh stephen biden's devoted much of his
political career to international
affairs
i would say his record's not
particularly distinguished he opposed
what you might think was
the good gulf war in 1991 he then voted
in favor of
the bad iraq war in 2003.
i mean is there any given his long
interest and involvement in foreign
affairs
is there any kind of coherent biden
doctrine
i don't think you'd uh give it a biden
doctrine that would stand up to a sort
of close
logical uh scrutiny but there's uh a
series of principles that i think
you can tie to biden fairly fairly
easily and that's also true of
all the appointees he's announced so far
this is a very mainstream very familiar
group
no outside the box thinking evident
among
any of them they like democracy they
like
all of our traditional allies they like
the idea of multilateral cooperation
but multilateral cooperation with the
united states as biden
put it at the head of the table they so
they believe in transatlantic ties they
believe in our allies in asia
they don't like russia very much and
they're increasingly wary of china
again this is nothing uh surprising it
is very much a team
drawn from the center of the american
foreign policy establishment
and that is by and large but bill they
must
realize i would have thought mr biden
and the team around i remember largely a
group it seems
even there of what we might call liberal
internationalists
they must realize that americans
that it can't just be the status quo
ante uh even though a lot of them are
team obama it can't just go back to
their bill can it i mean
they must realize that america's
appetite
uh for foreign adventures is close to
zero mr trump realized that and if they
do realize that
then in that sense the biden
administration is continuity trump
well i think in one sense you're right
they don't have any great appetite the
american people don't for foreign
adventures at the moment
on the other hand i agree with stephen
and almost everything he said it is a
traditional group tony blinken
comes out of a long experience of
liberal
nationalism and so does joe biden in his
own way
i think that you're right the world has
changed just in the 12 years
since biden became vice president with
obama
it's changed significantly and many of
the institutions
which trump undermined need to be
reinforced
but also need to be repurposed to some
degree and refashioned
and i think that's clearly on their
agenda in addition i think the
the notion of yes america as
sitting at the head of the table of a
group of interested and
equally committed countries with similar
values
is valid as well i think in approaching
china for example you're going to find
the dubai administration will continue
to be rather hawkish
in its dealings with china but it also
will tend to approach it
with a very different tone and a very
different approach
that is in joint effort with our allies
rather than trying to go it alone
that certainly did not work very well
under trump but i think
under biden that kind of joint effort
with our allies
presenting a common front will be more
effective
um we are going to come on to china
because it is such a big issue
for america and for the biden
administration but amber coming back to
the liberal internationals i mean
anthony blink in its state
looks pretty certain well qualified for
it
uh but he supported most of america's
middle east interventions
he's very much the liberal globalist
internationalist
this is a this is a dividing line for
the republicans isn't it i mean if this
is the way the bide administration
goes that does allow them to define
themselves
as something different and they will
think and perhaps
hope that they're more with the grade of
america's mood
today than that kind of liberal
internationalism
yes although some members of the
republican party are still very out of
touch
with the sentiment among the american
people that they're sick of foreign
intervention they don't want nation
building
they don't want to be a part of
international institutions that sell out
the american people like the world
health organization which helped china
cover up
the kobe 19 outbreak or the paris
climate accords which repeatedly allowed
other countries to get away with
breaking its regulations
while the u.s tried to abide by the
strictest of
the climate accords so but you have
mitch mcconnell
when trump was talking about pulling
another 2000 troops out of afghanistan
the past couple of weeks
writing a letter saying that it would be
a huge mistake for trump to do that
and that they need to continue to have
troops there and the establishment still
in the republican party is very much
neoconservative and really interested in
foreign intervention
you do have newer members of the party
like josh hawley that have
taken the opposite stance and applauded
the president's
attempt to get us out of forever wars
but
i don't think it's going to be as simple
as the republican party sees that biden
is being more interventionist and
therefore is going to take the opposite
tact because
uh the bottom line is that a lot of
these people really do believe in that
type of
foreign policy so actually rather than
being a a clear
clear blue water between the republicans
and the biden administration i
hear what you're saying it actually
could cause divisions in the republican
party because some republicans
will will actually rather like this kind
of biden foreign policy
as opposed to mr trump's most more
isolationist
uh one stephen you wrote uh the hell of
good intentions about america's
foreign policy uh failings uh i mean i
myself always thought the purpose of
american
military intervention was to teach
americans global geography but that
could be another point
it didn't work very well
just just team biden
therefore when you think of the hell of
good intentions mr biden's a
well-intentioned
person does it fill you with dread uh it
makes me nervous
although i'm willing to give any new
team you know their opportunity to prove
that they've learned uh from past
mistakes
certainly the instincts of this team as
i suggested before
are to see the united states as very
much a problem-solving country
in fact jake sullivan the designate for
national security advisor
wrote an article in the atlantic a
couple of years ago where he argued that
that was still the thing that made
america
exceptional the idea that our purpose
was to do good in the world
and to solve problems so yes they
recognize that there's no great
enthusiasm
for ambitious social engineering abroad
within the american body politic right
now the question is can they resist
temptation when opportunities or crises
emerge and remember there's going to be
a long list of countries lining up
to ask the biden administration for help
our middle east country allies are going
to want more help against iran
uh european allies will want help
against russia
our asian allies will want help against
china
and everybody's going to want help on
climate and of course the biden team is
very committed to doing something on
climate
and has put a former secretary of state
in charge
john kerry a special envoy that's a long
list of supplicants
lining up at the state department and
white house door
and if they say yes to all of those
requests this is going to be a very very
busy administration indeed
a very expensive administration
absolutely
so again i am hopeful that they have
learned from the past
but uh time will tell freddie what are
your thoughts on the uh
the incoming uh team biden or
particularly the foreign policy grant
i i'm even more cynical uh than stephen
is about this i'm sorry steven wasn't
cynical at all i wish he would he were
more cynical because i think that
you know the the swamp is back but also
the the cant
is back and you're going to hear a hell
of a lot of talk about values
and i've learned over the last 20 years
as a big fan of america that when
americans start talking about their
values in international affairs it's
usually bad news
and you have the a lot of this sort of
talk in the biden
uh the incoming team people like jake
sullivan it's a lot about how
you know the black lives matter movement
is also a foreign policy
issue so they are trying to sort of
create this idea of foreign policy as
uh progress and good in the world and
they're going to establish good in the
world
against evil which is populism and trump
and i just think that is fraught with
terrible terrible dangers
uh and i'm slightly nervous about it i
also thought it was funny that avril
heinz the new director
of uh intelligence one of the most
powerful people in the country now
promised that she would always speak
truth to power and i thought that was
just
that such a can't thing to say that such
a load of rubbish
that you uh as as director of national
intelligence are going to speak truth to
power because you are power you're not
some
radical who's doing good in the world um
so i
i find them very depressing and i'm and
i'm worried about what's going to happen
in foreign policy
well stephen the the sunni leaders
in the gulf have had they're up to here
with the palestinians now
they are much more frightened of iran
than the arab israel
which is why they're doing deals with
israel because they have a common enemy
in iran mr trump
was happy to go along with this he never
questioned the saudis about the murder
and the dismemberment of the journalist
he never pressed the gulf states to
liberalize in any way
he just saw this in hard real political
terms and in a way of getting america
even more out of the middle east as well
i think he took the view more we don't
really need the royal anymore so why are
we
there this is a difficult one for mr mr
biden i would suggest
well i think it is uh and it'll be a a
great litmus test to see
their willingness to say depart from the
conventional policy
i don't expect this administration to
devote the same effort to pursuing a
two-state solution
which i think is no longer even a
possibility that the
obama administration did that the bush
administration did that the clinton
administration did
you could even argue that they have the
opportunity for a real reset of american
middle east policy
uh they've said they'd like to get back
to the nuclear agreement with iran if
that turns out to be possible
uh that certainly would help our
relations with europe
uh and it would i think uh foreclose the
option of an iranian bomb for some time
to come
that won't be popular in israel in saudi
arabia and egypt or the gulf states but
in a sense what's already taken place
is is the united states essentially
saying to those countries
we think you can handle your own
security problems and you should stop
expecting washington to protect you
egypt israel saudi arabia the gulf
states together are
substantially stronger than iran for a
variety of reasons and we'll let our
partners in the region do most of the
heavy lifting while the united states
takes a more detached stance i think
that's an
opportunity for the biden administration
especially if they're really worried
about
china and they want to focus a lot of
their attention on asia
the other thing that has changed changed
before 2016 but it's now
increasingly evident is the united
states is no longer the unipolar power
that doesn't face
any uh potential great power rivals and
once you're in a serious geopolitical
competition you have to start setting
some priorities
putting the middle east on the back
burner would be a very smart move by the
biden team and i'm hoping that's what
they do
steven even this emphasis that the team
biden has been placing on trying to
reinvigorate the iran nuclear deal
that's it's possible to say look that's
old politics as well
it is not the prospect of a nuclear bomb
that really terrifies the israelis
they'd rather iran
didn't have it but they've got over 300
the israelis they and they know the
iranians are still
rational they may be ayatollahs but
they're rational one
iranian bomb in israel and iran would
cease to exist
that's what the israelis would do and
they have the fire power
and the nuclear arsenal to do that what
worries them
well where is the saudis because they've
been used against the saudi oil fields
are the high precision uh iranian
missiles
they're very state of the art they work
they got under cover of its audi
and american radar the hezbollah
has thousands and thousands of them
that's the problem and i suggest
that's what the biden administration
will have to come to terms with
actually i'd put it slightly differently
i don't think it's actually the
iranian capabilities which iran used of
course to
point out to the world that the maximum
pressure campaign
imposed by the trump administration
wasn't going to
sort of lead them to lower their tents
and surrender
i think the thing that really does worry
the regional powers is iran getting out
of the penalty box
in a sense iran has been placed in a
position of
economic and geopolitical isolation
over the last 20 or 30 years and the fir
and the iran nuclear deal was the first
step towards iran essentially
rejoining the international community
becoming a normal country along with
everybody else
and i think that's what really worries
the saudis the israelis
because once iran is able to regain full
engagement with the international
community and the world economy
it does have enormous latent power
potential
so 20 30 years down the road it might be
a formidable
adversary for those countries even if it
isn't right now
let's turn to mr biden's approach to
china now
he's perceived by many to be weak on
china he said some things about it that
he
doesn't like being quoted back to him
now but his team
and even across the democratic island
congress they're much more hawkish
than mr biden does amber how will that
work out
i just think it's difficult to trust the
bind administration on china because of
how wishy-washy he's really been about
the whole situation
he literally launched his campaign by
saying that china was not going to eat
the us's lunch
and that the idea that trump was trying
to hold them accountable for
terrible trade deals and intellectual
property theft was basically a joke
and then he has his own son hunter on
the board
of a state-owned chinese company
and he was not actually removed from
that board until
well into the general election i believe
it was actually the final month of 2019
that uh that hunter biden was actually
removed from that board supposedly
and then you have the fact that biden
was really open to the idea
of american cooperation with china
earlier in his political career
he voted to normalize trade relations
with china which
was one of the main things that allowed
china to start taking advantage
of the american economy and outsourcing
jobs
so the idea that biden is somehow now
going to be
the ultimate hawk on china i think is
really hard to believe
bill the the the people talk about the
differences between the biden
administration and trump won on foreign
policy
uh even on china but i'm wondering
whether
there seems to me to be quite a dc
consensus on china now which is
be tough with china we've been too soft
in the past the obama administration
was too soft trump may have been rather
brutal
or vulgar in the way he dealt with china
but he
moved to the right position and the
biden administration
will continue that toughness do you do
you think that's true
i think that they will take a relatively
tough line towards china but
our relationship with china is and will
be a rather complex one
there are certain areas in which we're
going to be competitive there are other
areas where we need
cooperation and collaboration um
so you have to be able to to work on
those different tracks
and i think the body administration will
prove able to do that there's no greater
china hawk than uh chuck schumer schumer
for example
um and that feeling that the chinese
have taken advantage
particularly of intellectual property
and other measures in dealing with trade
that they are taking a reckless course
in uh geopolitical considerations in the
south pacific
um all of that is is true and we're very
much aware of that we have to
be on guard against that and but we can
deal with it in a way
that isn't uh flaunting ourselves
towards them it isn't insulting to them
and we can do it in harmony with our
with our allies i think one of the
in retrospect one of the greatest
mistakes of the recent past
will be our turning away from tpp for
example where we were trying to set the
terms of trade
and establish a kind of rule of law and
common understanding
for trade in the whole of the pacific
minus china
we rejected it it went ahead anyway
there will be some way or another that
we can come to terms with that and
become active once more
and try to counter the moves that china
has made
in trade and in geopolitical terms and
in military terms for that matter
in that area so i think you'll continue
to see a
strong and forceful engagement with
china but one that seeks
cooperation and collaboration where we
can on those issues like climate change
that where we have to
work together and yet on other issues
there will be a relative degree of
firmness i i don't think there's a kind
of blanket approach to
to china that will work as amber
suggests
i'm interested that you mentioned the
trans-pacific partnership because i
other than just wanting to show he was
kind of against free trade
or free trade deals i was always puzzled
by mr trump just pulling out of that
because it was the potential alliance of
america's allies
uh of countries most of them democracies
uh
all worried about china all wanting
america's presence
in the eastern specific as a
counterweight prepared to be america's
allies it was a trade organization
but it would have led to much more
countries unlike a lot of america's
european allies prepared to spend money
on defense
you are prepared to spend a lot of money
on defense
when you think of all that would it not
make sense for a biden administration
with its belief
in alliances as well and friends
to revive that to join it again uh
in some terms we've moved beyond that
they've moved beyond that in a way
i'm not an expert again on that part of
the world but nonetheless i do think
that yes that would be
a reasonable thing to pursue there will
be problems within the democratic party
that he'll face uh to do so
but presidents in the past democratic
presidents for example bill clinton to
face those in the past
and have dealt with them um so i think
yes that might very well prove to be
something that he could do they would
want i think to to
present it in a way that there's some
change that makes it better
it makes it different from what it was
but nonetheless i think that's a
real prospect well you better look out
because britain might join that
trans-pacific partnership before america
does it
there's a lot of talk in london that
that's the quick way to do 10
11 free trade deals right away just join
that and it's a part of
the world the british know very well and
still have a presence in and so on
uh i was interesting foreign street
journal
um said yesterday that uh
china's only friend in america now is
wall street which i thought
was a great line but is it true it is a
great night i think there is a bit of
truth to it
it's still quite a good friend to have
though
of course wall street's quite friendly
to mr biden as well particularly now he
hasn't
appointed elizabeth warren as treasury
secretary
well i think going back to something
stephen and bill was saying i think one
of the interesting things about the
trump presidency in foreign policy is
that he got rid of all these
embarrassing
things that america needed to say out
loud like they needed to say to china
our trading relationship is not
reciprocal you've been taking advantage
of us for ages
there have been grumblings about that
for ages in america
but it wasn't sort of government policy
to do anything about it ditto
nato you know you had grumblings about
other nato members not doing their fair
share trump comes out and says it
in his bruce vulgar way and makes
everybody feel very uncomfortable
but i think the opportunity for the bud
administration now is they can take the
fact that
trump has moved that conversation on and
they can now say well
that is our starting position and we
don't have to be aggressive and
uh feel like we're winding you up about
it but yes we do expect you to be
reciprocal in your trading relationships
or yes with nato
you do have to pay your fair share so i
think trump has has been beneficial in
in a foreign policy center
amber i was interested when i came on to
china you immediately mentioned
so is hunter biden when we come to talk
about american chinese policy
is that going to be the equivalent of
the democrats going on and on
about mr trump and russia
for months years after the election
is that is this going to be the mirror
image of that
it definitely has the threat of being
that way i think the more republicans
actually hammer that point
well after the election the more people
are going to
think that it's really just a sore loser
tactic and even when trump was really
running on the idea of the hunter biden
emails
for the last couple of months of the
election it really turned a lot of
people off where people just really
weren't that interested in it
so i think republicans would do well to
learn that lesson and probably
not focus so much on that point when
biden is dealing with china i think it
does speak to
perhaps biden's friendliness with china
but i don't think it would be right for
people to
use that well into his administration as
an
example of you know how he's especially
going to govern i think
because in the end the mueller report
concluded that there was no collusion
the russia had certainly tried to
interfere in the election but the really
dynamite point were
the claim rachel maddow and msnbc and
all the rest of them
saying it was night after night the the
trump people had colluded with the
russians
that turned out pretty much not to be
true
um and i found it hard to believe that
hunter biden really in the end amber
will have any significant in fact they
destroyed the word significant
just any influence on on biden's foreign
policy
to china surely right and i don't think
hunter biden's
deal with china was ever something that
was
hinting at illegality or corruption
but really just showed more generally
the globalist inclinations of the biden
family because hunter was profiting a
lot
from working for a state-run company
that you know was owned by china
and i think that speaks more to the fact
that this neo-liberalist regime that
biden is going to be overseeing is one
that's
perfectly fine with global corporations
uh taking advantage of america and
really powerful people profiting from
them
it was good it was good of biden to
sorry i just it was good of biden to
clarify that hunter will not have a role
a government role in in the
administration i think that was a that
was a smart move
on his part so he's not going to be the
ivanka
of the biden administration steve
steven just i mean i can just trying to
look strategically at the
uh biden foreign policy i obviously
i can see uh where you know he's going
to be more multilateral he's going to
try and reinvigorate america's relations
uh with its allies
and so on he's going to try and bring
america
what he will see back into the
mainstream of western foreign policy and
i get all that
but it does turn out that trump was a
watershed on u.s global policy
no more unvarnished free trade mr biden
i doubt is going to
change that very much the europeans need
to do more for themselves
and europe is no longer as important as
it was anyway to america
mr biden's team probably agrees with
that the pivot to the pacific
starting with mr obama has continued
will continue under mr biden
a tougher line with china which seems to
be the new default position
in washington so when you add all that
up things will be done in a different
way there'll be a different tone
there'll be different emphasis
but strategically will there be much of
a change change
uh this is a there's a great question uh
there's
always this tendency to believe that
presidents as individuals are going to
have enormous impact
that's why you focus on you know what
did biden vote on when he was
in the senate or what did his son have
business dealings
if you're thinking about china for
example you're talking about a country
with an economy as large as ours this is
a major great power competitor
and the idea that this is going to be
determined by hunter biden's business
relationships
or for that matter by the fact that
ivanka trump wanted to do some business
deals in china too
i think is is sort of preposterous this
is going to be
uh i think is something that the biden
administration takes uh
takes very very seriously there is going
to be a considerable amount of
continuity more than people might think
because some of trump's instincts on
foreign policy were exactly right
europe needed to be less dependent on
the united states
by the way that's something every
american president has complained about
since dwight d
eisenhower at least uh certainly
that uh hyper globalization as it was
being pursued
uh was not a good idea and that needed
to be revised and
you know if uh joe biden wants to join
tpp he's gonna have to face down the
bernie sanders wing of the democratic
party
it might make sense to do it from a
strategic point of view
i would support it for that reason but
it's not going to be an easy sell
i think the biggest thing to remember
though is that style
to some degree does matter and trump's
style was counterproductive
right he tried to go up against china on
trade all by himself
right he didn't get japan on his side he
didn't get south korea on his side he
didn't get
the european union on his side when he
confronted china
on trade and therefore he didn't get
very much china didn't
alter its trading practices despite all
the pressure
he was under the one final point i'll
make here is
uh the the elections takes us back to
where we started
the election showed that the country is
still somewhat polarized
and that's a problem for the conduct of
foreign policy
because when biden goes out and tries to
reach agreements with other countries
tries to get them to make adjustments
makes promises to them of if you do this
will do that
other countries have to worry that in
four years
donald trump comes back somebody from
the other side comes back and starts to
unwind
everything that was done in other words
the pendulum keeps swinging
back and forth and so in a sense for
american credibility
it would be better if we were more
unified
biden has said he wants to do that but i
think that's going to be a very heavy
lift
for him to what extent do you think it
is possible with china to get other
allies to sort of publicly
stand in opposition to what china is
doing i mean we saw in britain
uh it took a lot of pressure from the
trump administration
to get any sort of move on huawei the
tech giant and
and we eventually backed down on our
commitment to doing 5g but that took
incredible pressure from the us to do
that
i just wonder particularly regional
allies
against china let's say how easy is it
for america to get them on side publicly
on site so that they are seen to be in
opposition to china
the there is a trade-off between the
economic relations that many of these
countries want to preserve with china
and their growing concerns about china's
power
here the united states has one asset and
that's been the fact that chinese
diplomacy over the past five years
has become increasingly malevolent
the so-called wolf warrior diplomacy
which seems to
regard insulting other countries as the
way to make friends
and build influence the fact that china
has punished australia for
asking for an independent inquiry into
the origins of the
coronavirus etc all of these things have
made it easier for the united states to
make the case
that other countries in europe and asia
have to be increasingly concerned about
china's growing power
possibly china's growing ambitions so i
think the conditions are there to pull a
lot of countries together
and in fact the response to 5g to the
american effort to control huawei and
very
in various ways is encouraging as is the
european union's recent
decision report calling for greater
cooperation across the atlantic on
digital technology and digital
governance all of it clearly inspired by
concerns about china
so i think the ingredients are there for
a multilateral response uh to china
whether they can pull that off is again
one of the things that's going to be on
there
i think very high on their to-do list
can i pick on one part yeah
i've been here for roughly 30 years and
i notice every four years or eight years
when there's a new president
there's a british historian or a
professor of international relations who
comes out with the book pointing out the
continuity between
even though there's been a change in
administration and even a change in
parties
but that's perfectly understandable the
personalities change the tone changes
and tone makes a very great deal of
difference
but the strategic interests of the
united states did not change and insofar
as one president
is accurately reflecting and channeling
the strategic interests of the united
states
the other one's policy is going to bear
some similarity so i think that's
an understandable phenomenon it is
indeed because
it's strategic and and in post-war
american history
there has most of the time there's been
a consensus on america's strategic
industries
across the aisle uh there of the bulk of
both of the major parties
spectator is doing its bit standing by
australia against china at the moment
we're
drinking as much australian wine as we
can get our hands on
uh there's a plenty of it at
the various supermarkets across the uk
uh
let's finish with mr biden's approach to
brexit we don't need to spend too much
time
on it mr biden was against it as was the
whole uh
u.s foreign policy establishment team
biden was against it
but it will have happened by the time he
is inaugurated so what can he do amber
well it seems like not much he's going
to have to grin and bear it
much like the troop withdrawal from
afghanistan biden has
signaled tepid support for that idea
much the same will happen with brexit
he'll
smile and nod and internally the
establishment will be very upset about
it
but they will have no choice if they
want to continue their good relationship
with
the uk for them to go along with what's
happening
you see steven here here's the deal as
mr biden likes to say
uh he might not like brexit well he
doesn't like brexit
he might not like boris johnson a lot of
team biden think there's a there's a
kind of trumpian element to
boris johnson there actually there isn't
but that's what they think
uh he will want to deal more with the eu
and of course there are
uh um offenses to be mended there after
the trump years there's no
question about that but if you look at
every one of mr biden's strategic
foreign policy goals coming back to
strategic as
bill was saying rebuilding the atlantic
alliance
you need britain to do that with the
second most important
member of that alliance free trade we
are the biggest voice in favor of free
trade
in the global economy re-entering the
paris climate agenda
we're there we're hosting the big
conference next year in glasgow
getting european allies more interested
in the pacific you've
mentioned that too they had to do that
britain is the only country with the
military resource
to be able to help deployment in the
pacific with two
world-class aircraft carriers and
australia is a close
ally providing prohibitive protection
there so my point the
rather low windy point is even is that
he may not like it he may be worried
about the good friday agreement all the
rest of it
britain is an essential part sometimes
the essential part
of a lot of his strategic foreign policy
goals
it's nice that you think that britain is
that important
but i think that may not be quite
correct uh and here i'll actually uh
echo this idea of continuity i think uh
you know boris johnson was under the
illusion that after brexit he was going
to go get a great trade deal from his
good friend
donald trump and what he didn't realize
was that americans regardless of party
are really quite ruthless bargainers
most of the time
and britain was not going to be as
important economically to the united
states as the whole european union is
and therefore
britain wasn't going to get a good deal
from the trump administration
britain's not going to get any special
treatment it seems to me from the biden
administration
uh as well no that wasn't what i was
saying stephen
that's not what i was saying i didn't
say that uh we'd get a free trade deal i
mean my own view is there won't be one
though i would suggest to you that a uk
u.s trade deal
would be a lot easier than a u.s eu
trade deal i mean mr biden
is unlikely to live long enough to see a
u.s eu trade deal
that would take about seven eight nine
years we could do one
and yeah but i wasn't arguing with that
because i don't think i was i i don't
think it will happen
i'm not sure it matters all that much
and we run a massive balance of payments
surplus with america why would we want
to screw that up you're the one with the
deficit
my point was that on his foreign policy
goes let's just take the atlantic
alliance
there is no way you can breathe new life
into the atlantic alliance
without involving britain at the center
of that strategy
right no my only point is that in a
sense you're right he will accept brexit
because brexit is
a done deal but it's not going to be a
suddenly uh return to the halcyon days
of the special transatlantic
relationship
and in some respects britain's value to
the united states has gone down
somewhat by brexit because in the old
days
britain was kind of a nice bridge for us
into europe
because britain was part of nato but
also part of the european union
now that you left the european union the
flight can go straight to brussels
without having to go through
london and we don't need london's
influence in the union
advanced american interests when you get
to brussels who do you talk to
we talk to the europeans who do we talk
to when we
you know when we go to the uk and on
defense
who do you talk to and defend with the
europeans
i i have a slightly different view from
stephen
in that i think because i was enjoying
the silence there from stephen for a
minute
i think the underlying military and
security
connections between the two countries
will remain very strong and very
important
they're part of the five eyes there's no
replacement for that really
that all will continue i do agree with
stephen that to one
to some degree the closeness of the
relationship
with great britain with the united
kingdom
in as a bridge to the eu that that
disappears and that there will be less
traffic on that bridge than there used
to be
but nonetheless i do think that
underlying
alignment of interest and strategic
interest
and values will remain and will remain
strong and exceedingly important for the
united states
no no i didn't i don't over egg
britain's importance in this at all and
in
many areas it will be either of no
importance or peripheral importance
uh the pacific being one area it may
have a contribution but it will be a
peripheral contribution
understand that i was just going through
mr biden's goals and then every
strategy goes and then every one britain
would be one of the key allies that he
will have not the only one
but a key but anyway let me come on to
the final uh
thing freddie that the uk media
sometimes it paints
uh mr biden as anti-british
and i think that's probably got more to
do with brexit and the groud friday
agreement and
you know his irish ancestors and so on
but i point out that during the
falklands war there was no stauncher
supporter of britain
on capitol hill than senator joe
biden i don't think he's he's right to
be concerned with the good friday
agreement i've got no problem with that
but i don't think he's anti-british do
you freddie no i don't i do think among
team biden there is a sort of reflexive
sense that as you mentioned earlier
they think brexit and boris are a bit
trumpy
and so they're a bit suspicious of it i
mean blinken has said
numerous things that sort of sound a lot
like what you hear from
very sort of ardent remainers in britain
which is you know these idiot
brits don't really know what they're
doing they've gone and cocked up the
whole system
uh and so i think there is this sort of
sense that
brexit is wrong and and even if their
strategic inter
interests are more aligned with brexit
or proves to be more in line with brexit
or mean that america should not have
some sort of prejudice against brexit
britain
i think the desire to signal their
objections and to show that they care a
lot about the good
friday agreement may end up overwhelming
and causing
tensions in the next couple of years
quite significant tensions i i fear
if there's no deal that will be doubly
true
if there is a deal the good friday
agreement will still
be pretty much intact so it won't be
such a big issue we're going to leave it
there listen i want to thank you all
uh all of my guests for joining us for
giving us
your time it's been a joy to have you
has been great to get your time and your
expertise and
insight and i know this is a busy time
of the week so i want to thank you for
that
don't forget those of you watching to
take full advantage of the special
christmas offer
for the spectators american edition 52
that's just a dollar a week and you get
a full subscription for a year to the
spectators
88-page monthly american magazine which
looks lovely
and full access to our brilliant
american website
updated hour by hour buyer with great
writing
even some humor which you don't often
see in american political magazines
we'll even throw in a free parker pen so
you can subscribe
and scribble down your objections to
what we're saying
straight on to the pages and then send
it to us go to
dot u s slash christmas spectator dot u
s
slash christmas in order to subscribe
now if you start
for more american coverage freddie has
his own podcast americano
which is a must listen you'll find it uh
all your podcasts
there at spectator dot co dot uk
americano but from all of us here
at spectator tv that's it for now thank
you for watching
see you next time bye bye
you